I tell you what a week first Maro Robbie
gets snubbed at the Oscars then Taylor
Swift gets booed at the football
game if you know a rich blonde bombshell
give her a
hug um
yeah no the only uh only bottle blonde
who did good this week was Donald
Trump he uh he
won
yeah he won the uh now he won New
Hampshire I mean and and of course very
gracious in defeat as
always he he he he beat Nikki H was the
only hope of some go past Trump now that
didn't happen so he's Furious his whole
speech is about how Furious he is that
Nikki hel is staying in the
race and I get it it breaks a lifelong
precedent where he finishes first and
the woman
lead oh I kid Donald Trump it's all in
good fun
uh no uh I know he's going to you know
it's boy it's sad it's the whole thing
is over now there not even a race to
follow but that was always
fun uh and Trump is beating Biden you
know now in the National polls pretty
strongly and um all my Democratic
friends are saying relax it's a long
time before the election CU yeah that's
what Biden's whole card is
time uh
no that's what we got to get used to it
this is it this is the race Biden and
Trump the race is over uh this is bad
news for the country I think uh very
good news for people who build ramps on
debate
stages uh you
know you know that
uh Bill
Clinton Bill Clinton uh has been on of
office for 25 years is still younger
than both of
them I'm not kidding about that that is
a true
fact their their combined age is 158
years old uh the first the first debate
is going to be at the Museum of Natural
History
uh well I don't
think I don't think there's going to be
a debate I don't think either one wants
it I don't want it you don't want it
let's just because neither one of them
is really up to it they're starting you
know what's trending on Twitter dementia
Dawn
because
because Trump was talking about Nancy
Pelosi during uh January 6 but he kept
calling her Nikki Haley Nikki heli did
this he also referred to the uh
president of North Korea as Ray Don
Chong I I thought that
was
yeah
you know what else dementia Don said
this week this is a direct quote I don't
know what it means no one does he said
word for word we are an Institute in
powerful death penalty we will put this
on even Biden was like what the
[Applause]